[Musica]
il neurochirurgo e scrittore leonard
era affascinato dalla figura di leonardo
david
e si occupa per molto tempo di capire
l'utilizzo straordinario che egli seppe
fare del suo cervello
secondo slam il genio di leonardo è da
attribuire ad un incredibile
integrazione tra emisfero destro e
sinistro del suo cervello cosa che
farebbe di leonardo
una prova evidente del potenziale
immenso della mente umana
d'altronde questa storia che noi
utilizziamo soltanto qualcosa come il 5
per cento del cervello è cosa nota
una leggenda metropolitana più o meno
fondata che tutti almeno una volta nella
vita abbiamo sentito ripetere però sarà
che come scienziato individuare degli
schemi ricorrenti è una parte del mio
lavoro ma a me questo 5 per cento fa
subito venire in mente un altro fatto
sul quale noi cosmologi ci stiamo
rompendo la testa da ormai più di mezzo
secolo
però forse è meglio andare con calma e
capire prima che cosa sia un cosmologo
un cosmologo è uno scienziato che studia
l'universo come un tutt'uno un sistema
con le sue proprietà ed una sua
evoluzione
a me piace pensare alla cosmologia come
a una disciplina tra le più antiche in
assoluto una ricerca che ebbe inizio
quando un nostro preistorico antenato
alzando il capo dal fango in cui giaceva
e volgendo lo sguardo all'immensa
vastità del firmamento per la prima
volta nella storia si chiese dove mi
trovo
da allora certo la cosmologia ne ha
fatta di strada arrivando ad essere una
scienza moderna tutti gli effetti poco
più di cento anni or sono
ciò nonostante a dispetto degli
innegabili progressi nella nostra
comprensione dell'universo
ci troviamo ora dinnanzi ad una curiosa
quanto strana realtà dei fatti
comprendiamo soltanto circa il 5 per
cento del contenuto dell'universo certo
uno potrebbe dire grande come l'universo
è già tanto se ne conosciamo il 5 per
cento
lasciatemi spiegare quello che voglio
dire è che ciò di cui conosciamo il
funzionamento la materia di cui siamo
fatti noi la terra il sole stessi così
come tutte le stelle e le galassie che
ci sono nell'universo
beh tutta quella roba lì
ammonta appena al 5 per cento del totale
e il resto il resto non è che sia vuoto
il resto è qualcosa di completamente
diverso e per ora c è oscuro un
cosmologo come me quindi è uno
scienziato che cerca di capire che cosa
sia questo universo oscuro nel quale ci
siamo trovati ad abitare innanzitutto
uno potrebbe chiedersi come siamo giunti
alla conclusione che la materia
ordinaria costituisca soltanto il 5 per
cento del totale provavano a metterla
così provate a chiudere gli occhi
coraggio
adesso immaginate un campo di grano gli
intolleranti al glutine possono pensare
una risaia un granturco adesso pensate a
il vento che accarezza le spighe
informati di questa immagine nella
vostra mente ora non riuscite voi stessi
a sentire il soffio del vento ma siete
in grado di ricostruirne la direzione e
l'intensità osservando l'ondeggiare
delle spighe potete riaprire gli occhi
in maniera simile a noi cosmologi
osservando galassie ed ammassi di
galassie
ci siamo resi conto che la materia
ordinaria
i buoni vecchi atomi che conosciamo così
bene non bastano per spiegarne i moti e
le dinamiche
abbiamo bisogno di altro e a questo
altro abbiamo dato il nome di materia
oscura possiamo pensare alla materia
oscura come all'ossatura stessa del
cosmo un enorme colossale continente
sommerso dal quale emergono come isole
le galassie una ragnatela cosmica nei
cui i nodi laddove c'è la materia oscura
e più densa e concentrata le galassie
nascono e si sviluppano certo queste non
sono che delle metafore utili per
crearci un immagine mentale di ciò di
cui stiamo parlando
sono poi i dati misure sperimentali
osservazioni a dirci che la materia
ordinaria non è sufficiente a spiegare
questi dati ma abbiamo bisogno di questa
materia oscura
ci troviamo così nella curiosa quanto
spiacevole situazione
in cui sappiamo molto bene quale sia il
ruolo giocato dalla materia scura ma
paradossalmente brancoliamo nel buio
quando si tratta di definire cosa essa
sia una cosa però l'abbiamo capita la
materia oscura costituisce il 25 per
cento del restante contenuto
dell'universo ricapitoliamo 5 per cento
noi cioè materia ordinaria 25 per cento
materia oscura totale 30 per cento e
mario anche ancora al 70 per cento
allora se la materia oscura via sembrata
strana
tenetevi forte perché ora sarà anche
peggio però per capire quale sia
l'ingrediente mancante è meglio forse
fare prima un breve ripasso della teoria
del big bang
secondo cui l'universo ha avuto inizio
con un grande scoppio
seguitemi nel ragionamento da una parte
abbiamo l'universo che inizia ad
espandersi a seguito di questa passatemi
il termine esplosione dall'altra però
dobbiamo ricordarci che tutto ciò che
c'è nell'universo è soggetto la forza di
gravità
la quale tende ad attrarre ogni corpo
dotate di massa
abbiamo quindi due andamenti
contrapposti un espansione dovuta al big
bang ed una contrazione dovuta alla
gravità
ci troviamo quindi di fronte a un bivio
o l'universo andrà continuerà ad
espandersi
o forse succederà qualcosa di diverso
perché quale sarà questo destino
possiamo provare a pensarci se c'è
abbastanza materia da far sì che la
forza di gravità da essa e su di essa
esercita da rallentando l'espansione a
un certo punto riesca a fermarla del
tutto a questo punto la forza di gravità
essendo l'unica rimasta in gioco farà sì
che l'universo inizia a contrarsi
andando verso a un collasso finale
se al contrario la quantità di materia
non è sufficiente la gravità non
riuscirà mai a fermare completamente
l'espansione potrà soltanto rallentarla
sempre di più ecco quindi il dvd cui
parlavo abbiamo una contrazione
gravitazionale un collasso da una parte
e un'espansione sempre più rallentata
dalla
terzi un non datur come dicevano i
latini non si vedono altre possibilità
quindi sa che cosa diamo incontro
proviamo a fare un sondaggio chi pensa
che andiamo incontro a un collasso
gravitazionale alzi la mano dubbiosi
agente ottimista niente collasso invece
chi pensa che andiamo incontro in
espansione e rallentata per sempre
dell'universo decisamente decisamente
molte più persone
credo che qualcuno un'idea se l'è fatto
comunque l'aveva in ogni caso noi una
risposta a questa domanda già l'abbiamo
e la risposta è nessuno di questi due
scenari
vi sentite presi in giro francamente
credetevi anche noi
eppure in questo caso sembra proprio che
terzi un dato la risposta sia una terza
completamente imprevista e inaspettata
possibilità l'universo si sta espandendo
ma in maniera accelerata
siamo giunti a questa conclusione
soltanto dopo aver analizzato una grande
quantità di dati e osservazioni ma
possiamo riassumerla così sembra che
sulle immani inimmaginabili scale del
cosmo le galassie siano immerse in una
qualche forma di sostanza per la quale
la gravità funziona al contrario cioè
respinge invece di attrarre a questa
davvero misteriosa sostanza abbiamo dato
il nome di energia oscura ed essa
rappresenta esattamente il 70 per cento
mancante del contenuto dell'universo
chissà forse abbiamo bisogno di un altro
genio come leonardo per riuscire a
svelare il mistero che avvolge
l'universo scuro forse solo utilizzando
il 100 per cento del nostro cervello e
riusciremo un giorno a scoprire la
natura dell'energia oscura e della
materia scura
sta di fatto che questi ed altri
interrogativi sono ciò che tiene
impegnato ogni giorno i cosmologi e
sprona la nostra curiosità al fine di
ideare teorie innovative modelli
matematici ed architettare esperimenti
rivoluzionari
perché come diceva un altro grande del
rinascimento galileo galilei l'universo
è un libro scritto nel linguaggio della
matematica ed un esperimento è una
domanda che noi poniamo alla natura
lei risponde sempre si tratta solo di
fare la domanda giusta
grazie
[Applauso]